When I talked about these institutions in place, these structures that are in place that the undergirds and
We're going to continue doing what we're doing, and that is to enforce the law and be fair about it,
and that's all we can do.
person is receiving help. We are yet to
find anything like that, and we've looked.
parasites, primarily hookworm – something most experts assumed had disappeared in
the U.S. The Alabama state health department refuses to acknowledge the validity of the test results.
supports poverty. And until we change that, it doesn't matter who the face of it is. Or who's in charge.
sanitation. Catherine and a team of
researchers from the Baylor College of
more alarming: the resurgence of
parasitic disease linked to poor
and it's leaking water right now. So I have to squeeze the clothes out and hang them
up in the house before they got something to wear to school.
And I got holes everywhere in my house. And mold and stuff. My washer was torn up
The house ain’t fit to live in, because animals and stuff come inside my house. Possums and stuff.
trying to pretend like this problem does not exist.
The unfortunate part is that the government should be partnering with us on finding real solutions instead of
There is no evidence of hookworms in Alabama.
We are yet to find a person, a person's name,
Medicine conducted a study that found
two in five participants had intestinal
sanitation in the cities, where there is
sanitation or a large municipal system,
and terror inflicted on black people by
white residents who wanted to maintain segregation.
These inequalities – spatial, racial, income and property – intersect with something even
Montgomery to honor the thousands killed in lynchings across the U.S.
Lowndes County. A memorial was just
raised a 20-minute drive away in
and plantation power. The Equal Justice
Initiative documented 14 lynchings in
of slavery, racism and segregation cannot
be separated from the current situation.
in the U.S. lack access to proper
sanitation. Catherine believes the legacy
I have no way to take care of this problem myself.
of low-income rural communities across
America. Nearly half a million households
decide what to do. Period. It's our of our hands.
toilet, but also the safe collection,
management and disposal of feces in wastewater.
In 2015, the UN said access to sanitation is a human right. That requires not only access to a
that criminalize it? It's saying that you've broken the law. That's not a
We still write notice of
violation. I don't know why people call
by her department. In recent years, the
department has stopped taking people in
misdemeanor and fine. Sherry says the
department's role in all of this is only regulatory.
in the areas of town where black people
have traditionally lived.
it generally stops at where the black
community starts, or people have problems
changed and there are black elected
officials in place now, you see where the
Against the backdrop of all of that, Lowndes County has, although it has
In the 1950s, it earned the nickname
"Bloody Lowndes" because of the violence
The history of this
area is entrenched in white supremacy
institutional racism is still in place, and that's one of the reasons why we have these problems.
The institutions were set up based on
racism, and in some cases, I think that
Lowndes County is just one piece of a larger picture that shows a pattern of neglect and marginalization
If the person refuses to put
in a system, it goes to court. The judge
and the use of septic tank systems. We
don't criminalize anybody.
strategy, that's that's what we do. We
regulate the permitting, the installation
it "criminalizing."
When you get a ticket for speeding, does
this county to court, but it continues to
cite homeowners, which could lead to a
arrest warrants in Lowndes County for
septic-system violations brought forward
Cheri Bradley is the director of environmental services
anywhere from $6,000 to $30,000. The annual per capita income here is $18,000.
the ones often needed to handle
the soil in Lowndes County can cost
particles and microbes filter out
bacteria. But in hard, clay soil, water
ground is good for planting, but it's not
good for on-site wastewater treatment.
Here's the reason. Most on-site septic
systems rely primarily on the soil
soils of the Carolinas, and the
of Alabama decided that they wanted to
expand and put their plantations and
bring their slaves here. And the people
But it also earned the nickname because
of its rich, dense clay soil.
to put the infrastructure in place to
keep the population poor. And a lot of
these populations are largely people of color.
to provide our own water. People had
their own wells. And then when the USDA
County is environmental racism. When we first moved to Lowndes County in the 1960s, we had
at the Alabama Health Department. Between 1996 and 2001, 24 people were issued
United States. You're talking about
poverty. That's not for the health department to fix.
Yes, Lowndes County – and I
agree – is the poorest county in the
So while an ordinary septic tank might
cost between $5,000 and $10,000,
can't really move. And that means
wastewater can't be filtered properly.
itself to treat wastewater. The effluent
flows out of drain holes, where soil
those slaves that were brought to this
area to work the ground. Because the
that are in Lowndes County, a lot of us –
including myself – are descendants of
and settled this area. They came
here because that they had worn out the
Our soils were the reason that people came here in the first place
Belt." That's because the majority of the
population is made up of black Americans.
Lowndes County sits in the middle of a
region in Alabama known as the "Black
sanitation part. So as a result, a lot of
these areas intentionally were, I think ...
started providing water to families in
rural communities, they left out the
victims of benign neglect. You know, the
lack of investment in those communities
A lot of what is happening in Lowndes
find a solution to the sanitation crisis.
Catherine Coleman-Flowers grew up in Lowndes County, and has spent the last 16 years trying to
Yes, I called this America's dirty secret. And I think that this is a problem that has gone on for years.
It make me feel bad. Because I don’t want all my stuff just coming out here and running on the ground.
get rid of their own waste. And with
nearly a third of the community living
I have no septic system, m-hmm.
Because you have no septic ...
people. Behind her mobile home is a pool
of human excrement. That's because she
Why can’t you flush the toilet paper down?
that people don't have access to
sanitation. Pamela Rush is one of those
the civil rights movement are still
being denied access to basic human rights.
March of 1965, ended in horrific violence.
Months later, the Voting Rights Act was
What started out as a peaceful protest
from Selma to Montgomery, Alabama, in
things change, we're going to continue to
create what we've created.
It could be somebody who looks like me.
It doesn't matter. Until these structural
facility. An estimated 80% of
residents have to pay out of pocket to
below the poverty line, people like Pamela have resorted to straight-piping into fields, yards and ditches.
Many homes in Lowndes County are too
scattered for a central wastewater
What’s that feel like?
Because it will get stopped up. The line and stuff get stopped up.
has a straight pipe going directly from
her toilet into the backyard.
an area of extreme rural poverty, where
families who live in the epicenter of
There are parts of Lowndes County,
Alabama, so impoverished and neglected
follow that same trail today, from Selma
to Montgomery on Highway 80, you'll find
passed. Black Americans are now
guaranteed the right to vote, but if you
We are going to walk nonviolently and peacefully, to let the nation know we are tired now.
Black Americans paid for the right to
vote with blood and bruises.
Ain’t nothing I can do. I can pray, 'cause I don’t have nothing.